the show has come to an end so I want to
know who cried the most and what did you
guys take from set
who cried the most
like we were talking like when we
wrapped yeah in real life what is the
tea ah yes I think that's you I did I
cry I cried a lot yeah yeah that was bad
oh I'm a crier yeah I mean that was a
pretty emotional moment to be here I
wouldn't say like you're a crier you
cried at everything that one was a big
that was a big day yeah it's a big day
yeah yeah did you guys cry was there a
tear I cried with um I cried once and I
cried with Benjamin Norris who plays
Trump and we were like walking through
the Sherman Oaks High School hallways
and they were tearing it down and uh
yeah we had a moment correct yeah I feel
like I have to say that I did but I
don't I don't really think I did cry I
was definitely like a little emotional
but I I don't think that I ever had any
tears really yeah flow out of there but
I was definitely emotional I think I was
like a little happy just like proud of
us and and grateful on that last day
more than I was like upset it hit me
later it hit me like a few months later
where I was like okay but yeah yeah so
the love triangle is such a huge topic
of course and fans have their favorites
will they be satisfied with the ending
yeah I don't know if there's a way to
satisfy no like there's no way you know
like there's no way that sounds like
everyone definitely not triangle is too
set in stone so there's very divided
fronts on this yeah you know yeah either
there are parts of the fandom that will
be really excited and parts that will
probably be in some slight despair
tough love so okay if you could go back
to yourself when you first auditioned
for this role
um what would you say to yourself
you're gonna get it
don't worry don't you freaking yeah
don't even worry about it good job
congrats congrats all of you guys will
say that no I I
um I don't know I think I would just say
like get excited I guess if I knew the
outcome I think I would just say like
get excited for some of the best what
three and a half years four years of
your life it definitely like changed my
entire life it was a dream come true in
like every which way so I think I would
just tell myself like whatever you think
it's going to be it'll be better and it
was so true true I feel like for me
um yeah I definitely didn't think I was
gonna get it just because of like where
I was up my life at that time plus like
you know just like not being someone who
knew they wanted to be an actor so if I
like could go back in time and tell
myself uh my 17 year old self would
probably just like punch me and be like
you're weird you're crazy you're some
psychotic Brown woman please get like
away from me so I wouldn't say that I'd
probably say something more reassuring
about like hey like life stressful right
now but you're okay be nicer to yourself
right now that's what I'd say yeah the
rest they can have a surprise I don't
want to give myself a breath I don't
want to miss this Butterfly Effect it
probably would just stay silent yeah
right like what if you say jinx it I
know yeah so I'll just say like
something reassuring for their mental
health they needed it Terminator myself
you know
show meant to each of you
first
I mean
but no you go ahead you got something I
I mean I don't it changed my life it's
it is what it is and it um opened up a
lot of doors and I made a lot of
wonderful friends along the way and you
just realize how lucky you get sometimes
on a set where
do you you know get along with everyone
and go on to work doesn't feel like work
so yeah I'm grateful I'm happy and I'll
never forget it that was beautiful oh
what about your percent I mean like we
have such great jobs where for some
people a job is a job and that's totally
respectable right but we are so
privileged to be able to do the thing
that we love with like without worry you
know we get to do this amazing job so
that's such a huge huge gift at a young
age I get to find out what I want to do
with the rest of my life when a lot of
people are still figuring that out which
is totally fine and acceptable but um
there's so many different gifts and then
of course the people that come along
with the journey and then the bigger
than ourselves impact that the show
means so much to so many people around
the world and is changing what our
expectations are when we're consuming
media when we're consuming film and TV
so there's so many different levels
really yeah I mean it's hard to add to
that but it's literally just echoing
what they both said we created a family
which I know sounds cliche and a lot of
actors say that but like I think that
we're going to be with each other in in
each other's lives for years and years
and years to come like we just really
had kind of a bonding experience from
shooting in a time that was very
formative I think in all of our lives
and careers and that sticks with you
it's like this was sort of all of I
think our big breaks I mean I know like
Darren you you had some other stuff but
this really was the show was massive and
like my tree said like it's loved by so
many people around the world and that's
something that I think will always Bond
us together throughout like the test of
time I mean I think we'll be 60 years
old still talking about the first and
the last day or or different memories
and things from set so it's uh it's very
special and we're very lucky to be a
part of it awesome